私たち人の youtube プリエたで巨土井がクリスマスツリー
するぞあああーー
なんか青1本奴も欲しいかも700なんかかぼちゃみたいなんだけどこれ超起きました
と母位カボチャよるしっかりやつですよねじぇりか阿蘇弱化4ランタンなんであんまの
集中しすぎかなあ踊るぞ
残り60
これ60分だゆんじゃないけどあーえー
じゃあもう
クオリティ上げてでしょうかな
あかあか系が多いには影が薄くでちょうど下ブラウれた応力が集中しね
ちょっとがミシンは c
上のほうに毛の色ちょっとあえて明るい緑とかも入れちゃう
葉っぱの緑とが支えて相殺ですね
でもできなかったよりはいいですからねいいですね遊べます堂水キールとか逆に何か
クリスマスツリー座っクリスマスと言ったらとかもできますですねなんかねーかななん
かプレゼントボックス家にちょっと作っているんです何か
品
あ
あー素晴らしいそれは簡単に作れそうだそうですね
泡白ねうん
しますと言ったらサンタクロースますさん達ですよ
ああ頭に描いた瞬間に無理だなって思ったせ
ねやっちゃって宮村伊澄ずおじいさんおじさんの顔とかだけ作ってウォッチわー
おじさんの母も難しくなってくれ
ん
確かに何か傾向として集中している系科卒の見ちゃった
まんべんなくではないですね行ってるところもあれば
黄色飛んだような
黄色が足りていないあでもこれはクリスマスツリー
んですね誰が見てもそうだな
を若干垂れバトリオ束をなりましたね
やっぱクリスマス言ったら月んなんで大か一応考えてますね
それで生きた鳥を出す気なんだからから戦争ですね
海外だったらだってえちきんだろうと言う
丸焼きみたいな
彼等は何か鳥の形になってる奴付取り替える
トッピングみたいなん
太っ腹ないかな誰かなんか
クリスマスといえばクリスマスという罰したとかどうですかおおーー
自民なんかうカンタンちょっと曲でで逆に恥ずかしそう
ない人に赤い葉くぐる赤い箱これって今からで高齢者事例
なるほどがないかな
今の議論の中心っていうのはまだ時間があるからもう一個建造物んが周りにお化け
みたいなをガンガン
あってもいいかなとした広げ4日のこの白いやつ
hiro 何よ
雪広げるの良いですねあそれがちょうどダイナマイトでこの氷ぶっ放すとかいやこれ
機材のみブッ飛んだーーだったら終わりですかパパちょっと離れたやつからや汁とか
でしょうと強いす熱リストね
あっ
3出奔でもう一回作り直して
時間いっぱいですね
い山p っていうのが化けたんですけどねはじめ者じゃないってものか
うっじゃあちょっといやなんか8番取っちゃうっかマジやんのみそんな沸騰ですかモー
ルっ子ます半径くらいじゃあちょっと離れですかっっ2個並べると
あっ一気に倍増するあの号ます半けっっ
盗んだ奴が現地が吹っ飛ぶんですようん
可能性は1個ずつ手のでやるんであれば1個ずつ
なんか楽しそうだから服なんてこと tnt てやつでしょ
それに5打差何食うちょっという部分えっこういう場が止めてよ俺あれでは氷で氷1個
ずつを離れニーモリっ子いてみましたあそこかあぁアレだ本材ていた
アーネれすぎて戻ってこれはだけれどもう者
5これ火をつけるのは直末ところで火をつけるのはえーっ
誘致しああ
t 4
教え投げようコツ
どんどんても揃ってきますけどねそうね破壊もねうち10名はやめ
わー
ああわあああでも大謝恩ない
すべきだしてもないならいいかしかにごますくらいああこれサイズ的に攻略弾き飛ばす
にはちょうどいい
ブーバーさんのプレゼント box のすぐ横ですっないですねサー
ねま応えまあの床に置いたの天田をいただければおきます僕あじゃ
中に配置しないこのちょっとほってさいああなるほどぞ
あるそれでいいかもね通人国会もやしてみません朝倉さんやいやパイン
ぎゃーわーお
ええ感じで処理された
すごいいいね
ブーブーもう何か入っに感じ
音がすごい殺すよああああ
おっ
多いけど意外に近いところでやってらっしゃるんですねあったんですね
ちょっと浮いている氷がう
ent 動画になるんだ
塗ってい
nt あった a
poso
爆弾処理班みたいなんで
じゃあこれ行こうかなって
こっちのなんだのツリーじゃない側に置けばいいんじゃね多分こいつです
ビッ
お夏がって時にも破壊してほしいなあああ
変更3個ないどのくらい弾きと思うんですよね
行っちゃった暗黒大以上前から嫌じゃあはいじゃあここわかる神コレでっかいからこれ
ですか
いやーこっちこっちあこれですかそう今1個置いてあるじゃんこれ横にじゃあ
ブーブが吹っ飛ぶんだろう強いぜひつけたっつけますいます3個だよねこれ以降つけれ
ば米カメラマンってますからねあーやべえって
ううぅううああ
順番に行く患者では穴がでかい具合
これ効率円主導で壊した方が早かったんじゃないって言ったらうん a で階
なっちゃうんだしたに陥っちゃうんだなぁなんか横にくっきりから落ちますよねじゃあ
この上に配置してぶっぱの人に惚れ
ゆっ早い
写真は意外と全然そんなアップてもない
爆弾たバス絶対近畿ハマると思った始めちゃったじゃあ
t ルティすごいじゃあこれたくさん置いたらすごいバックでねあーくそめちゃいいや
いえすごい離れてちょっと行ってみます
あ所で耳にちなみに行きたい
やクリスマスツリーが見える範囲でそうですねこれ各いい景色で
受け床の上だ1まってどこにいるんだ
は充実どこ行った報告しろ入れなきゃいけないからされだ
勇気の方だ
エナ六家めっちゃおいてみていいですかいいですよ
黄金所属もうちょい近くていいよそのさ
ツリーと一緒に見たいかなあっはぁ私はそれを張ってそれよりちょっと北海なあこっち
の祝飛んできたら怖いだねこれ釣り吹っ飛んだ僕じゃないですピアソン上から吹っ飛ば
ないでしょ
ここら辺で相当よまだ者いきます
やばい今いいアングルで撮れてます
カメラマンいいアングルです今でに日目です非常にいいですよこれはかもね別の神戸の
左下にいますはっはっは
ネオ見えてるんだ近いからっ
が結構通院でる何か作りますね何個だ10位マンツーロックです
これどんなもんなんですかねでもあの感謝とは
余裕ですよね
これ高さとかは関係ないんですかねこうやってブワーってやってるがあっ
ダイナマイトツリー作ればいい入学していくかあっいや by hi
やばいね賑やかな感じにはなりますよねクリスマスらしいん
でもへたすれ作ったものがなくないん
その作ったものがなくなっちゃう可能性ってああいうブースカ
この tnt によって爆弾が爆弾吹っ飛ばしてツリーのほとんできたら
バーンそこで行っちゃうね
ツリー化してきてるけど大丈夫それます
母
すごいよねんか始めたけど裾米茶の呪怨の1スケールぐらいやばいです
嚶鳴から見ても結構なサイズ感になってきてるよ
土台が完成してるね今あぁ悪いですよねこれ
餌付けは1個つければいいんですよねけどよですけれども
あウェッジなどっちがいいですか
うん下のほうがやござい音だしたつけます
水でもなんかこじんまりとバカンス相談風に見えるけどね
死体がどんどんそのまま掘られていくかもしれないですねサージャー上からつけたん
ですかね
って上から作ってますね明日から打ったダイナマイトアドバイスが来てますね王を
います愛顧薄い2うわーうわーは言えないなぁやばいいよ
ん
わー
ああああああああ
これ下手したら溶岩とか寝ちゃうんだよねよってみるちょっと
金みたいなてつか解けたこれじゃああーあーあんが起こってみればここ
こっちの方向性だったそんな中とも山門付くれるいいわねこっから見るクリスマス
ツリーもカッコイーソンと絡んだよ星の上に緑が1個
あっほんとだやればいいんじゃないんです
こちら阿久根社長逆に
穴掘りアプリ
ほんとなんかツリーがすごい長くなってる穴面白いな
いやぁーな面白いですよ私マインクラフトやってるときだいたい残ってますよね
あっはぁ
あのフォルティが爆破ですよねじゃあ曲私
掘ってるってらっ追ってるんですよこれがまた
鳥が可愛い
動いている
すげープレゼントボックスがちょっとそれっぽいです赤と黄色やそれっぽい
なんかないかな他にクリスマスといい
的教育で全山がねーよを考えたら
歩い三角とかでもいけるのか3角でもいいですいちごケーキ
はぁ
持ってい
おすごい拡大している
ちょっと私も証人はいじゃあヒカキンさんぜひここにケーキを作ってください
ですね共同作業はい
そっちはそれはハ穴掘りは進んでますかやばいばがする技するで何だ何だ何してんだ
ふーん
何をしておられ深いとか穴を掘っていますがまたさっきのところ大
でそこ溶岩出るまで者
何の任務なんですよねなんかここにそれもさりげなく質問ですねこれ
tnt 1個
は白い怖いね
こっちでも爆発音はでこない
うわ多いからですよねそうそうこのお話を聞いた時に僕が当初予定した感じになりまし
た
村井さんと社長さんが tnt デーはしですよねそうよそうそうだぞ
僕達が姫3型カタナをはじめに最初もうね
さっきすごい崩れ落ち方しましたね見るのなのかあのあー
バッカー輝いみたいなよくそういう映像ありますよなんか
なーんてしたから崩れてくるある
覚えて私のはるか足の下に肇社長の名前は見えるぞ
そんな方も今思いませんだと思いましたあじゃああれだわかったこれ見たんやってある
ありますじゃあはじめ処女ダイヤ見つけてさあ星にさー
ダイハツブーン出せる待ってるからはっはっはて駄目だ
違うんだジャンプ探したものは違うけれども大丈夫違うだろてです
洋食か10年の差ですね
か意味です
べきなアワビとかみっ
ホンダふっか日本もどうぞまあ詰めて水ブツッ
まあ水だしちゃったのはこれが最後に離れてくださいこれが面倒だったからどうぞ
えっらい参道がいいんだここで日陰さあしたですしたした
表示さこっちで少しですねっ
王立技術をリジーサーフもうちょっと上これ大
ここにいたんですけどここを見て下さいここの穴
横に彫ってるんですねまさかこれツリーの内部よ
あっ入りましたこれ絶対は考えてるこれどこか
ただちょっとかなり雑に作ってきちゃったのでちゃんとここから呆れて言葉を得る
ところです実はしツリーの中に入る
謎の木かつえほんとが
結構たぜなんでちょっとね徐行かわかんないですよねこれ全然あっあ
でたんで1回スーツです
着々とこれを負った
そんな頭から効率なかったみたいに行けますけど
いやいい加減スピアーでも菓子の大蛇見つけてほしいなあはじめちゃん
頑張ります第8ターンでも水石に水色の
水色が混じってるやんなるほどそれをもう皆さんのクリスマスプレゼントにしますよ
国交多い
マインクラフターにおけるダイヤっていうのはどれぐらいの価値がある
いろいろ幅が広がるので a のあるじゃね探せば結構普通に
まあ何ことはないんですけどでもやっぱり
何だろうマインクラフト動画における通過点の大事ななるほど
th
していた